good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight they called it the week
that changed the world
that was richard nixon's description of
his visit to china in 1972
nixon was the first american president
to engage directly with china's
communist government and he was right in
the end
that visit changed everything for a
while they told us it would all be good
for everyone relations with china
would help every american that's what
the experts said
free trade would make us rich and they
continue to tell us that for decades
even after the evidence mounted
it wasn't true even after china entered
the world trade organization
and immediately eliminated entire
portions of our economy along with the
millions of american jobs they sustained
most of which never returned the media
mostly ignored that part it didn't
affect them and they weren't interested
factory workers could learn to code in
fact some workers may have learned to
code but then ironically
china began the wholesale theft of our
country's intellectual property
our coding which was the only thing we
had left once our hard industries died
and the media stayed silent as this
happened they didn't seem angry about it
they didn't seem bothered
at all by china's relentless espionage
campaign against the u.s government
which was the biggest and most
successful spying operation since the
cold war
reporters didn't find that interesting
either instead they screeched about
russia and george floyd in hope that we
wouldn't notice
any of it the biggest stories of the
decade ignored
so why did they do that why the
deception we can only speculate
but we can tell you that as so many
americans were being hurt by china
including hundreds of thousands of them
killed in their prime from imported
chinese narcotics a small group of
americans
was prospering in every age there are a
few who get rich from the china trade
in our time most of these people have
clustered around joe biden
he's their candidate we learned today
that a man called
bob iger may become america's next
ambassador to the people's republic of
china
bob iger runs the walt disney company
few have made more money from his
connections to the chinese government
and few are as openly grateful for it
as bob iger is and that's not slander
it's true iger admits it
watch today is a celebration
of creativity and collaboration
commitment and relationships a triumph
of imagination
and
anything is possible for those who
believe bob ogger said
that was 2016 at the opening of a new
disney theme park in shanghai but it
took more than belief more than
faith to get that deal done bob iger
didn't explain what
disney had been willing to do to get the
park opened in china
according to an account in the new york
times times bob iger met personally with
china's propaganda minister in 2010
and promised that he would use disney's
global platform
created by walt disney a patriot
to quote introduce more about china to
the world
in other words disney promised to spread
chinese government propaganda
and that's what they did disney began
working directly with the ministry of
culture
in china and that partnership produced a
film called born in china
the movie promised to quote showcase to
the world the spectacular wildlife
and natural beauty of china iger also
granted the chinese government a 30
share of the disney management company
that ran the shanghai property
plus a 57 ownership stake in the
shanghai resort including revenues
for merchandise restaurants and hotels
now put yourself in his position you've
watched for decades as the government of
china has hurt your country
has hurt your fellow americans if you
were a patriotic person would you jump
into business deals with the people who
did that
bob iger did so if you're starting to
get the impression that bob iger will do
anything for a buck slow down for a
minute that's not entirely true
he's not that guy bob iger is a
sensitive soul he's a man of deep
conviction and principle
at least when he's here in america just
last year bob iger announced that it
would be quote
difficult for his company to film in the
state of georgia
why because the state of georgia was
moving forward with a law
that would ban abortions after doctors
could detect a fetal heartbeat
bob iger was offended by that he'd like
more americans to abort their children
and he's willing to pay the price for
that high ideal
but in china there's a separate slate of
standards
china can throw ethnic minorities into
concentration camps
china can weld corona virus patients
into their apartments until they starve
death and has
china can crush protesters with tanks on
television
none of that bothers bob iger in fact
china has it right
he says apparently including the forced
abortions
bob iger loves china and he's not shy
about saying so
they welcomed us there and let us build
shanghai disneyland so we have a good
relationship with the government of
china
and local governments in china and our
access has actually increased over time
i generally as a at least as the ceo of
the walt disney company
look at china quite favorably
seems shocking now how can that man be
in the running but you should know that
joe
biden isn't thinking of nominating bob
iger in spite
of what you just heard him say his
praise for the communist government of
china
biden may nominate bob iger because of
what he said
sucking up to china is the qualification
and actually bob iger is just following
the lead of the biden family
today our reporter brooke singman
obtained a 2017
email from joe biden's son hunter to the
chairman of the chinese energy company
cefc
that email offers quote best wishes from
the entire biden
family it goes on to urge cefc's
chairman to
quickly send a 10 million dollar wire to
quote properly fund and operate
the biden family's venture with the
company now cfc you might remember is
the company that offered hunter biden
30 million dollars for quote
introductions
alone introductions to the people his
father worked around introductions to
his father
the company also reserved a 10 equity
stake for someone called the big guy
who's the big guy
well according to hunter biden's
ex-business partner the big guy was joe
biden
now if all this seems a little too
brazen to be real consider that our
media class and the silicon companies
they depend on for revenue operate in
exactly the same way
it was just four years ago today
december 16 2016
that our national news media was united
on one point
nothing they told us was a bigger threat
to the safety of this democracy than
foreign meddling in our politics it was
happening before our eyes we were told
and our president-elect donald trump was
probably complicit
in that meddling not by china but by
russia
the boston globe ran an op-ed to begin
this way quote a specter of
treason hovers over donald trump that
same day december 16
2016 the washington post owned by jeff
bezos
china's biggest front for retail sales
in this country
published a piece with this headline
quote fbi in agreement with cia that
russia aimed to help trump win the white
house
and of course national public radio cnn
nbc every major news organization dashed
off similar
stories making the precisely same point
and yet none of these outlets are saying
word one
about the emails we just read you the
biden families attempt
to get money from our chief adversary on
this globe which is the government of
china
they say nothing about bob iger's
propagandizing and profiteering in china
they celebrate the idea that he might be
our country's representative
to the government of china now why is
that
because our media are dependent on china
they won't let you view stories about
hunter biden because those stories are
really about china
and negative stories about china are not
allowed it's becoming obvious
just hours ago a major digital
storefront in the united states banned
the sale of a video game
because it mocked the appearance of the
president of china
not of our president but of the chinese
president that's not allowed
and yet in the face of this joe biden is
accelerating our sucking up to china
installing chinese propagandists in the
u.s government to represent our
interests
in front of china this will continue to
happen
every day in this country and if you try
to say anything about it your words
might disappear too